[Applause]
yeah I've decided I want to be a better
dater so I've actually stepped ghosting
on people I know I actually texted a guy
ago stood on I felt so bad I was like
look I'm so sorry I was so rude you
deserve better
and then they texted back thank you
apology accepted
do you still want to go out and then I
have not responded loser so I'm really
trying to like be out on the dating
scene it's so expensive though right
like being single is way more expensive
than having someone because I got a
supplement stuff so I get a lot of
massages because I miss being touched
and I see a lot of psychics because I
miss being lied to
but I love all the dating apps I think
they're great because you can always
tell what part of the country you're in
depending on the guy's photo every time
New York LA the photos are the same it's
just like headshot headshot guy in a
boat flying first-class
check out this Tiger all the time but
then I'll go to like the middle of the
country or the south and then suddenly
the photos are guy with dead deer guy
with dead fish guy cradling a ar-15 shot
this tiger
there's a dead animal in every single
photo like I'm gonna see and be like oh
my god if he did that to the deer going
to murder me but then a lot of fun
places like New Orleans or like Austin
Texas Portland Oregon and then suddenly
the photos our guy in top hat on
rollerblade
just no sure Rayman suspenders hi my
name is Oreo I'm a pansexual warlock
life-partner non-dairy creamer were poly
[Music]
I've been living here for four years in
LA and it's very difficult to be a woman
here because every week we had like a
new beauty product that's sold to us
it's just like buy this cleanse that put
that in your butt right and they're so
crazy their gets so nuts that I feel
like I'm on some YouTube prank show
hosted by a 19 year old boy who's just
like we told these women if they put
crystals in their vaginas their skin
will clear up and their exes will come
back let's think what happened
[Applause]
Gwyneth Paltrow I'm sorry dr. Gwyneth
Paltrow she tells women to put these
Jade eggs in her vaginas cuz apparently
Jade makes you glow from the snooch out
so now you have all these women being
like I'm glowing I'm like you're
sweating you're going into shock come on
and they're like well it helps with my
kegels I'm gonna tell you guys right now
if anyone here feels like their kegels
have come loose for any reason just do
your Kegel exercises that is all you
have to do it is also the greatest
exercise because it's the only one when
you say it out loud people automatically
start doing it
am I wrong you know there's someone here
was just like oh my god I forgot you can
imagine I don't like these things right
a lot of reasons but my number one
reason is I don't even know this about
me but I'm a proud American okay and
Jade that's made in China
I'm not outsourcing my vaginal exercises
to China okay we're getting American
stone in there we're getting coal you
guys are right back to work and then if
I sneeze I get a diamond it's pretty
great
[Applause]